Det är det här som är problemet och det har vi varit inne på till.
Raktpornalitet är det alla söker men varumärkesbyggande är emotionellt.
Man vet inte riktigt vad det är som vår människor att nappa i ens eget varumärke eller ens egen produkt.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni har omsatt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rendesbra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Jasper Nordling till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Välkommen Jasper.
Tack så mycket, var det kul att vara med.
Du har ju ett James Bond villain name, Jasper.
Låter ju jävligt bra på engelska.
Det är ju...
Har du reflekterat över att Jasper är mycket bättre än Jesper?
Ja men det har jag.
Jasper är ju den anglo-saxiska versionen av Jesper.
Så när man säger Jesper internationellt så säger man ju Jasper mycket enklare.
Så det är egentligen den internationellt anpassade versionen av Jesper.
Så den är jag mycket nöjd över att bära idag.
Jag förstår det, jag älskar ju namn som har lite uns i sig.
Så Jasper, jag bara tycker om det.
Joel är ju precis värdelös på engelska.
Jewel.
Det är liksom, det är ingen som tycker om det namnet.
Så någon gång i framtiden får jag byta till något coolare.
Skitsamma, det är inte det vi ska prata om idag.
Idag ska vi prata litegrann om dig.
Kan inte du ge oss en liten hisspitch om vem du är och vad du sysslar med?
Ja, jag sysslar ju med att bygga varumärken och jag gör det i grunden som projektledare.
Jag har en lång reklambakgrund på bureauer inom media, PR och reklam.
Jag har varit i IPG-nätverket, jag har jobbat för internationella PR-bureåer som Edelman, Deportivo och jag har också varit på DDB, som är en av både Norden och världens största reklamrörer och nätverk.
Så i de världarna har jag befunnit mig och jag har alltid jobbat med kreativ kommunikation, försäljning och varumärkesutveckling.
Vad är kreativ kommunikation till skillnad från okreativ kommunikation?
Men det handlar väl om rationella budskap och emotionella budskap.
Jag har jobbat med det jag tycker når ut till människor som engagerar och förtjänar människors uppmärksamhet och tid.
Och jag har alltid haft en tro på att det är starkare än den rationella cellkommunikationen som kanske inte berör lika mycket.
Vi snackade lite här innan och jag hade ett avsnitt här för en dag, en och en halv månad sedan eller sådant där, med Mats Gehorsson som också pratade lite varumärke och marknadsföring.
Och han är ju väldigt mycket åt det teoretiska hållet.
Och du är också mycket åt det teoretiska men också mer åt det praktiska.
Kan du förklara lite skillnaden där och vad det konkret innebär och vad du sysslar med som inte är bara att sitta och snacka?
Ja, men jag har väl alltid varit mer av en do-mer och jag har alltid, i de här kreativa miljöerna som jag har förordats i, haft fördel under att kunna omge mig med människor som är smartare än jag själv.
Man får inte, nej, nej, nej, innan fan jag hör redan vad du håller på.
Det finns liksom två regler i den här podden.
Den ena är att man inte får hålla på med massa jävla blygsamhet och sådär ödmjukhet, utan man får tänka att du är på LinkedIn, på steroider, och sen får man inte heller prata om mig, utan det är allt fokus på dig och så skit i alla de här snälla meningarna.
Berätta nu vad du sysslar med.
Ja, men så här är det ju att i den världen som jag jobbar i så finns det ju teoretiker som är supersmarta och kan allt det här om varumärken.
Det jag gör är att jag omsätter det de säger i praktiken och styr kunder till att faktiskt uppnå resultat.
Så att jag tar det som sägs och så omsätter jag det i projekt och i arbeten och arbetsgrupper för att nå fram till målen helt enkelt.
Så när andra pratar så tar jag in och är mot dem i projekten för att det också ska ge effekt och leda till de resultaten som alla teoretiker säger.
Jag fattar, och från början så var du anställd, men nu driver du en egen byrå.
Ja precis, efter egentligen många år av att ha befunnit mig i startup-världar som investerare och rådgivare så har jag nu sett det hovet av varumärkesbyggande och att många behöver hjälp med det i tidigt stadie.
Och där har det också funnits en begränsning tycker jag, i den kreativa branschen att de stora byråerna t.ex.
tar in tid mot startups för att processerna ser så oliniära och de kan vara så stökiga att man vill inte jobba med dem.
Då kanske det blir så att man måste gå till mellan stora byråer som tar emot den för att man inte har något annat val, för att man vill ha pengarna och då anpassar man inte sitt arbetssätt till den här typen av företag.
Så där vill jag klima in och hjälpa grunder helt enkelt med varumärkesbyggandet för att lägga grunden och komma på en bra start.
Jag förstår lite, vill du förklara lite vad byrån ni har gör och vad den aktivt sysslar med och vilka jobbar ni bara med startups och vad innefattar det?
Vi skapade Liron för att vi såg ett behov av att bygga varumärken med tidiga och skalande bolag.
Vi började jobba med processer som vi kallar för Minimum Viable Brands, där vi precis som man tar fram en Minimum Viable Product också börjar bygga ett varumärke.
För det är få som tänker på varumärket och det kan ju gå lång tid innan man börjar tänka på varumärket för att man är så fokuserad på byggandet.
Så det här är en process som går att applicera långt in i företagsresan.
Det kan ju vara ett varumärke som är helt nytt, det kan också vara ett varumärke som behöver en refresh eller det som behövs behövs börja byggas.
Och där ser vi att vi använder vårt mindset och vår metod kan komma in och börja jobba med varumärket snabbt.
Du pratar lite där om att det är ett problem med startupbolag eller att vissa byråer inte tar emot dem.
Kan du förklara lite problematiken där så jag fattar?
Jag tror att stilen på varumärket som vi har det är att det är allt man gör.
Stilen på varumärket när man går till någon som jobbar traditionellt med varumärksutveckling det är att man bara landar i kommunikation.
Här är det ju ett starkt varumärke.
Det bygger ju rektering och branding och försäljning.
Man bygger varumärket i allt man gör.
Det gäller att ha en förståelse för det och ett arbetssätt som passar de behoven.
Jag tror att om man går till så som det ser ut idag och man jobbar med founders, som är starka företagsbyggare, då gäller det att förstå deras verklighet och hur stor in kring bolagsbyggandet också kan vara en del av varumärket.
Det där får man sällan om man går till en traditionell varumärksbyrå som bara tittar på att göra kommunikation.
Är det precis liksom i uppstarten då som man besöker er, eller när är det man snackar med er?
Man kan komma till oss när man startar upp, man kan komma till oss när man vill skala, det kan vara en pre-seed-runda, men det kan också vara en A-
eller B-runda när man börjar ta in kapital och man kanske börjar tänka på att utveckla varumärket.
Men man kan också komma till oss när man känner att det har gått i stå, att man känner att vi inte har lagt så mycket tid på varumärket, vi har inte grunden, den kommunikation vi gör, den får inte någon effekt, därför att det man möts av när man träffar oss, det är inte tillräckligt attraktivt.
Vi skulle vilja att kläder tog på oss en ny kostym eller att vi kläder oss i andra kläder som gör att vi blir mer uppmärksammade.
Då kan man också komma till oss.
Det är hela grundtanken.
Man kommer till oss när man behöver en refreff och börjar bygga sitt varumärke.
Jag tycker att det är så jävla...
Jag är en av de där som aldrig har fokuserat på varumärke utan liksom hamnat någonstans på sidan kring det.
Sen bygger man väl varumärke ändå.
Men det har liksom inte varit någon aktiv, stark tanke.
Men när man kommer till dig då säger vi, går vi in i sätter och ser ett rum då och så säger du, ja tänk på att vara glada.
Vad förväntar man sig i?
Vad ska jag som kund komma med?
Vad är det ni erbjuder?
Hur går dialogen till?
Vad är det man tar fram?
Vad är det man snackar om?
Jag har liksom aldrig varit i den här processen.
Kan du inte förklara för mig som att vi sitter på en date här och du förklarar vad du sysslar med?
Ja precis.
Då kommer man till oss och så säger man att just det där du sa att jag har aldrig tänkt riktigt på varumärket men jag har ju byggt en affär som ändå genererar någonting och som har växt organiskt men kanske behöver jag tänka på varumärket.
Vad gör jag då?
Då kommer man till oss och då sätter vi oss ner och så går vi igenom allting och så tittar man på ska man vara rolig?
Ska man vara seriös?
På vilket sätt ska man sticka ut?
Man sätter sig ner och tittar på hur ser marknaden ut?
Vad gör våra konkurrenter?
Och hur kan vi skilja oss från dem?
Och hur kan vi ta marknadsandelar genom att ha en egen identitet?
Och sen börjar man diskutera hur den identiteten ska te sig.
Det kan ju vara genom att vi ska vara kaxigare, eller vi ska vara lugnare och mer trovärdiga, eller vi ska vara roligare.
Och ofta så väljer man ett kreativt territorium som man ska gå in i.
Och i det territoriumet så bygger man sen färger, formalitet, bildspråk.
Man tittar på grunden, stjärnan, skälen i företaget.
Man skriver ett manifest.
Det manifestet har man sen med sig som en karta egentligen.
Så när du sen är inne och gör små justeringar på sajten eller i din copy kring produkter till exempel, ha med dig i den här kartan och tänka på att när vi skriver så uttrycker vi oss såhär.
Vi uttrycker oss inte sådär.
Gör man det i helrättar rakt igenom, kanske en hel produktratalog och i annonser, så kommer folk att börja känna igen en.
Man kommer att bli tydligare.
Tydligheten är jätteviktig.
Måste man alltid sätta sitt varumärke utifrån konkurrenter?
Du sa att man ska sticka ut.
Är det infallsvinkeln?
Varför är inte infallsvinkeln vad man egentligen har som grund i bolaget?
Och så får liksom, om det hamnar i kollision men om konkurrenter spelar det någon roll?
Hur mycket ska man justera och hur mycket ska man bara gå på det man redan gör?
Ja, det är ju såklart en avvägning.
Jag säger ju inte att man ska titta på marknaden.
Jag tror att när man tittar på marknaden och tittar på konkurrenter och tittar på kunder så måste man ta in all den informationen och sen göra avvägningen hur mycket man ska gå sin egen väg och hur mycket man kan följa det som faktiskt fungerar idag.
Men man måste också titta på vad man tror kommer att fungera imorgon.
Jag tror absolut att det är en avvägning.
Det är precis som när du själv går på ett mingel och funderar på hur du ska ta kontakt med människor eller sticka ut eller vilka samtalsämnen du väljer att prata med andra.
Det är väldigt enkelt att omsätta dig i den typen av metaforer och sen försöka tänka på ditt varumärke eller likadant.
Vad gör man om det inte funkar?
Om du går på ett mingel och du går fram och är såhär, ja men låt oss för enkelheten skulle säga att du är ett total asshole, så du går fram till alla människor och bara tja, har ni sett vad ful världen är idag?
Så är det din ingångspunkt för dagen.
Det kanske inte funkar då.
Då kan du ju bara byta ingångsvinkel.
Men om du nu har satt ditt varumärke, när kan man sätta fel varumärke?
Ska man börja om då?
Ja, jag tror man kan sätta fel och jag tycker det är ett vanligt misstag.
Det är där vi också känner att vi kan komma in och kanske testa att bygga ett minimum viable brand eller ett varumärke som kanske går in en prototyp på någonting nytt och sen testa det för att se vad som biter.
Jag tror ju att man alltid kan förändras.
Jag tror inte att man bygger fast sig för hårt.
För att oftast så, jag brukar säga att det värsta som kan hända när man gör kommunikation är ju att ingen bryr sig.
Oftast så tror man ju att om jag kommer ut fel i den här annonsen eller om den här inte får någon uppmärksamhet då är det egentligen för att folk tänker negativt om en.
Jag tror att man kanske upplever någonting som man inte förstår och sen så släpper man det och går vidare.
För att människor går inte runt och tänker på varumärken.
De är inte intresserade av varumärken egentligen.
Man är intresserad av produkter och tjänster som gör ens liv enklare.
Därför tror jag att man kan testa olika vinklar tills någonting sitter.
Det är klart att du kan inte gå ut och vara en idiot på det här minglet och sen tro att du kan komma tillbaka och sen helt plötsligt vara schysst.
Man får ju ha lite sund förnuft i det hela.
Men man kan ju absolut misslyckas tio gånger med att få kontakt med någon, men sen elfte gången lyckas genom att komma med rätt ingångsvinkel.
Det tror jag.
Kan du förklara lite om det här minimum viable brand?
Vad innebär det?
Hur stort är det arbetet?
Hur gör man den processen?
Det är ju egentligen, så skiljer det sig inte så mycket från ett vanligt varumärkesbyggande.
Mer än att man väbel in vissa frågor och vissa perspektiv i processen som gör att man kanske tar höjd för att ja, det är ett business to consumer varumärke idag.
Men vi kanske är ett business to business varumärke om tre år.
Hur ska vi redan nu tänka på vad vi ska säga i den övergången?
Eller hur öppnar det upp för att vi har en stretch?
Alltså att varumärket inte låser sig vidare att vara ett consumer brand.
För att sen bli väldigt kostfant att styra om det till ett business brand.
Det kan ju ligga i namnet, det kan ligga i lite hur man uttrycker sig, det kan vara att man bara tänker tanken.
Vad händer då om vi vill ställa om eller hittar en ny morga på två år eller ett år?
Jag tror också att det handlar mycket om att inte hamna snett från början.
Det kan vara väldigt lätt att man gör det.
Då blir det väldigt dyrt att korrigera.
Det har jag varit med om flera gånger i start-up.
Man går all in på en kreativ plattform som det så fint heter för att bygga sitt consumer brand.
Sedan efter ett halvår ser man in att vi ska nog bara vara ett business-bolag.
Har man inte väckt den frågan från början då är det lätt att man har spenderat en halv miljon varumärksplattform som någon konsultat har i fram.
Och den blir då värdelös.
Vi har verktyg och metoder för att det där mm, det ska bli lika hårt.
Okej, men så det du säger på något sätt är att många grundare när den drar igång, de har någon sorts överpassion och så går de all in på ett varumärke.
Det är det här vi ska göra.
Sedan som alltid så sker det någon sorts pivot.
Då får man lite förkasta det arbetet som har varit bakåt.
Hur hade man gjort det med en sådan MVB, får jag kalla det då?
Ja, fick jag säga MVB på amerikanska då, så låter det bättre.
Nej men det hade man ju gjort genom att ha de punkterna med i det individuala arbetet tillsammans med grundar.
Man sitter ner och pratar om de olika scenarierna som kan komma framåt.
Sen tittar man på olika utfall och sen designar man ut efter de utfallen helt enkelt.
Till exempel om namnet från början är, vi är ett viss typ av bolag inom den här kategori, men det kanske finns någonting i bakhuvudet som skulle kunna vara, i framtiden ska vi också kunna lansera de här produktserierna eller vi ska kunna pivota in i de här marknaden.
Då kanske man måste göra någonting åt namnet tidigt och börja fundera på det för det blir så svindigt att byta ett namn senare i processen.
Så att man liksom har den spelplan klar för sig.
Det tyckte jag var ett bra exempel.
Jag intervjuade här förra veckan så det släpps väl före det här avsnittet, men då snackade jag med bivaxfabriken heter de väl.
Och det är ett väldigt, vad ska man säga, det är ett lite begränsande namn i sig själv då, för de gör ju bivaxdukar.
Och det är svårt att gå utanför en bivaxprodukt då.
Är det inte dumt att gå för brett är inte halva grejen när man sätter igång att man vill nisha sig, att man faktiskt vill nå folk och få folk att fatta vad man håller på med, om man står för någonting.
Det måste vara ett större problem att folk inte fattar vad du gör än att du om femton år gick för snävt.
Precis, och det var ju inne på också att människor kanske bara inte förstår eller uppfattar det du gör om du är otidlig eller sänder fel budskap.
Jag tror att det är en avvägning man måste göra i början hur...
Helvet vad mycket avvägningar det ska vara.
Kan det inte bara vara logiskt?
Det är det här som är problemet och det har jag varit inne på tidigare.
Raktionalitet är det alla söker, men varumärkesbyggande är emotionellt.
Man vet inte riktigt vad det är som får människor att nappa eller engagera sig i ens eget varumärke eller ens egen produkt.
Här måste man ju...
Det finns ju bara för att göra det ännu svårare då, eller för att göra det mer avvägningsvärd så...
Man tittar ju mycket på vad är det som är go-to-market-strategi.
I den så tittar man på exakt vilken kund man vill åt när man går till marknaden, vilket budskap man ska sända och vad en försäljning är.
Men i varumärkesstrategin, där tittar man ju mer på vilka emotionella lager ska vi ha när vi går framåt.
Hur ska vi prata, vilka element som vi tycker ser bra ut, vad är det vi tror går på.
Alltså det är ju mycket mer, ska man säga, fluffigt.
Det är där man ofta gör misstaget att man tror att de där två är samma process.
Att en go-to-market-strategi är ju inte att bygga ett varumärke, det är ju att nå sina första försäljningar och liksom ta marknadsandelar.
Men varumärket är ju någonting som byggs på till kanske tre års sikt, eller på fem års sikt.
Men att go-to-market, det är ju vad vi ska göra de närmaste tre månaderna.
Och där är det ju viktigt att kunna separera dem och samtidigt kunna liksom lägga tid på.
Det är ju lätt att man går till go-to-market bara för att det är konkret, reaktionellt och ger snabba resultat.
Skulle du kunna hjälpa mig eller folk som lyssnar i att förstå vad är liksom rimligt att jobba med i, om vi säger under de första åren och de första anställda och de första, hur djupt ska man gräva ner, vad ska man tänka på, vilka fällor fastnar folk i, var du sätter folk i fel.
Alltså någon sorts förståelse för eller är det enkla svaret på att man ska ringa dig?
Alltså kan, vad är liksom?
Ja, jag kan alltid ringa mig lite senare.
Jag tror att den största fällan man går in i är väl att man blir så inåtvänd, att man blir så målstyrd att man börjar titta på vem kunden är idag, vad vill de ha, hur ska vi sälja till dem och hur ska vi kunna sälja det till investerare, det här som ska vilja investera i vårt bolag och hur ska vi sen växa.
Jag tror att man måste lyfta blicken också och fundera på där man är, skälen i varumärket och varför folk ska bry sig om en överhuvudtaget.
Det där är ju, jag kommer tillbaka till det hela tiden, att det är två olika perspektiv.
Jag tror att till en början så ska man nog vara så pragmatisk, att man, ja, vad är det för färger, vad är det för bilder, vad är det vi vill utstråla, hur vill vi att den som kommer till oss ska mötas av oss?
I text, i färg, i form, i budskap, och vad vill vi vara för kompis?
Varför ska man vilja hänga med oss?
Det är ju väldigt få som tänker på det.
Utan man tänker mer på att det har en produkt som kommer att revolutionera den här kundens liv och fattar de inte det, då har vi gjort något som är fel.
Men det är inte riktigt så när mänskliga hjärnan fungerar, utan vi är emotionella och vi nappar på det som vi tycker om.
Måste det alltid vara?
Kan det inte bara ibland vara att man säljer produkten för fem spänn mindre och är lite snabbare?
Kan det inte bara få vara så enkelt?
Jag tror att det kan vara så enkelt i korta cykler.
Det är inte så att världen står still och är öppet om än.
Så länge man är fem kronor billigare kommer någon att säljas.
Det kan vara så att det man är fem kronor billigare än, det kanske är plötsligt inte fungerar längre.
Då spelar det ingen roll om du är...
Alltså att människor inte vill ha det.
Då spelar det ingen roll om du är femton kronor billigare eller trettio senare.
Du urholkar ju värdet i din egen produkt genom att vara och sänka priset.
En annan grej jag tänker på är hur många jävla varumärkesingångar kan man ha egentligen?
Man kan vara såhär, vi är lyxiga och vi är roliga.
Vi är personliga, vi är snälla.
Men om vi tar till exempel modevarumärken eller smink som det finns två tusen av.
Vi har tur i gymmetrustning, vi är kanske 25 varumärken som säljer någorlunda mycket.
Men det finns vissa branscher som har hur många aktörer som helst som sysslar.
Finns det någon grej som funkar oftare?
Jag vet inte riktigt vad jag letar efter, men någon sorts ingång som funkar bättre?
Och är inte den redan överetablerad?
Ja, överetableringen är ju tufft.
Och jag tror att du vann efter ett recept.
Det är klart jag gör.
Som ska liksom fungera.
Och jag kommer ju vara den jobbiga personen som säger att det är inte det som jag tror är nyckeln.
Därför att problemet är ju att man vet ju inte vad som biter på människor.
Det är jättetvårt att egentligen, man vill ju kunna det, men det är jättesvårt att testas fram till exakt vad det är som gör att människor köper någonting.
Även om man tror det så får man ju svaren från människor att de ska handla på ett visst sätt, men de gör ju inte det i praktiken.
Det är ju era optionella knäppa-varelser och det är väl det som blir kanske vår räddning mot AI och allting.
Men det går inte att på en överetablerad marknad tro på att det finns ett färdig recept som gör att det är precis det som gör att man slår konkurrenterna.
Däremot så tror jag att testa man och ha ett öppet sinne för innovation och vill utvecklas så kommer man att vinna, men det kanske tar ett år eller två.
Man måste bara ha en tidlig bild av vad det är att satsa på.
Jag tycker att just de branscherna du nämner, de är såklart överetablerade, det är mycket pris och det är snabba konsumtionsvaror.
De har ett väldigt stort element av just det du nämner, men det kan ju vara de där 10 procenten på toppen som gör att man är någonting annat som gör att man vinner.
Jag tycker bara det är spännande.
Hur gör man den här?
Om du nu har ett varumärke då, och du märker att det inte riktigt biter mot kund, hur testar du vad som funkar?
Hur tar du stegen därifrån till nästa?
Det beror ju på vad man säger att någonting biter.
Det är ju precis som med all marketing väldigt konverteringsstyrt idag.
Och börjar man bara titta på konvertering, så riskerar man ju att hamna i det här tränskritet att man bara rapporterar siffror, och man vet egentligen inte vad syftet är med det man gör.
Och då i slutändan så vet man verkligen från eller till vad det är som har fungerat.
Men jag tror att det handlar om att ta fram exempelannonser, att ta fram nya budskap, att prova ett inlägg på social, se vad som fungerar, försöka, antingen så kan man ju vara en sån som tar baka på trender själv, eller försöker man skapa egna trender, att man liksom bestämmer sig för vad man vill göra.
Och som sagt, det värsta som kan hända är ju att det bara liksom flyger förbi människor.
Man ser ju snabbt vad som fungerar, och har man inte jobbat med det här förut, då får man ju doppa på en lite i den kreativa världen.
Och sen till slut så hoppar man i med allt man har, för att man kanske märker att någonting fungerar.
Behöver man aldrig bry sig om den existerande kundbasen?
Om du har en kundbas och du känner att jag ska göra en liten förflyttning här, ska man bara skita i att man redan har några som gillar en viss typ?
Ja, det vore ju farligt om jag stod här och sa till någon nu att nej du ska skita i den existerande kundbasen och bara försöka få nyliapetter i sovarn in i marknadsandelar.
Det jag skulle säga är väl att ja, du ska inte fixa det som inte är trasigt, men om du har en existerande kundbas och märker att den inte växer, nej men då måste du ju prova någonting annat för att få in nya kunder.
Då måste man ju tänka på nya sätt och innovera.
Där är ju varumärket en grundpelare i allt man gör.
Så då måste man nog gå tillbaka och titta på hur man ska uppfattas.
Sen tror jag att moderna varumärken idag kan inte bara vara på ett visst sätt.
Vi människor är så pass, inte polariserade men vi har så pass mycket olika intressen och det finns så mycket som fångar våra intressen idag och vi har så mycket särintressen och subkulturer därute att varumärken måste nog fundera på vem man pratar till och hur man pratar till.
Men att man har lite olika kostymer att ta på sig helt enkelt.
Att man pratar på olika sätt till olika människor för att bygga med den här kundbasen.
Det finns liksom inte en enorm kundbas där alla tänker likadant eller reagerar på samma sätt.
Och det är den stora utmaningen, för utvare sig så då funkar masskommunikation bättre.
Men du nämnde här att det är lätt att fastna i siffror, att man bara rapporterar.
Hur ska man mäta det om man inte mäter i siffror?
Jag hade ett bra exempel igår från en besöksnäring, där människor som kom och betalade i dörren var det viktigaste.
Men så gjorde man en annons med en QR-kod.
Och det ledningen egentligen, där man kunde köpa en biljett, även om försäljning utanför dörrförsäljningen var obetydligt för dem.
Men det blev ändå att man mätte den här QR-koden.
Det var det alla ville veta, det var inte framgångsrikt, för vi sålde inga biljetter på förköp på den här QR-koden.
Men syftet med annonseringen var ju att påvisa att det här finns.
Det här stället ligger här.
Dit kan du gå om du vill titta på en häftig utställning.
Det var ju det man ville förmedla och ta plats med.
Men resultatet baserades på det många som hade gjort den här QR-koden.
Och det hade den här marknadsrörelsen jättesvårt att förklara.
Och det är väl det som är grunden att i all form av marknadsföring så finns det både ett budskap om man vill att människor ska se och så finns det kanske en call to action som man vill att nåt ska göra.
Men då måste man bestämma sig för vad det är som är syftet med den anordningsen.
Så det är det jag menar med att man kanske drunknar i de här siffrorna, att man stirrar sig blind på konverteringen, men vad människor tycker och tänker om en, det blir man inte om lika mycket.
Det är svårmätt men det går ju att göra, det är fullt möjligt.
Men är det snarare det man ska mäta då, är det det man jobbar efter, är det det man söker kunders upplevelse av en, eller spelar det egentligen, är det folk som inte är kunder än, är det deras upplevelse, vad är liksom de goa kopierna här, du märker ju vilken vinkel jag kommer från med siffror.
Ja men absolut.
Men jag tror ju att du kommer från siffrorvärlden, du har konkurrenter som gör ungefär likadant, eller samma saker, och ni slåss som kunder, och ni gör det på en affärsmässig nivå, där ni sänker priser, och ni tittar på distributionskedjor och allt det där, och det är ni grymma på, och det kommer ta er någonstans.
Men jag tror ju också att om du får nya människor att pappa ögonen för just ditt varumärke, så kommer de att bära med sig det, och sen när de står inför valet mellan dig och en komponent, så kommer de att välja dig, för det är ju dig de har en relation till.
Och det där kommer ju instinktivt, och det kommer från ryggmärgen, och det kan nog inga människor riktigt förklara.
De har liksom bestämt sig innan för vem de ska beställa det på, och då kanske inte priset spelar någon roll.
Och det där är ju liksom en aspekt av din marknad, där man kan få liksom en advantage.
Hur mycket är bara att synas, och hur mycket är att man måste förmedla någonting?
Spelar det egentligen någon roll vad man har för budskap, så länge man fastnar i bakhuvudet?
Det där är ju intressant.
Jag har varit med om i de här uppstartsfaserna, där man har ont om tid, man har kanske lite resurser, men man vill ändå göra någonting med sitt varumärke, och man bygger kanske på ett sånt här minne med en viable brand, då kan det ju bli lätt så att det man tar fram kommer fort, det kan vara uppseenderäckande, det kanske inte är helt perfekt.
Jag som kommer från Storbror tänker väl att man kanske inte hade gått ut med precis det här, för fattar man riktigt, men samtidigt ser det någonting som man hajar till på.
De kampanjerna och den kommunikationen kan faktiskt gå ganska bra, för i målgruppen kan det vara någon som säger haha ni har med det där ordet eller det där kan man känna igen sig i.
Det skapar mer än känsla och det är någonting som inte är perfekt.
Och då har jag folk till och då får man också på mässor till exempel eller vad det nu kan vara, folk som kommer fram till den.
Gör man det där, sen ska man inte springa naken på stan för att få uppmärksamhet.
Det kan alla göra men det är ju liksom, det leder inte till något bra.
Men gör man det bara 10% mer, man bryter någonting så kan det vara lite.
Hur vet man när man har gått över gränsen?
Ja men det vet man väl.
Vet man det?
Ja men om man inte vet det, då tror jag att man ligger pyt till...
Då har man inte gått över gränsen.
Sen finns det ju sjuka exempel i världen på när man går över gränsen och det inte händer någonting men jag tror att den kompassen måste man bara ha.
Det är inget som jag lär ut.
Skulle vi kunna gå lite från detta och prata lite om...
Du började jobba lite med investeringar och liknande också eller du började investera lite.
Kan du lite berätta om det och vad du har investerat i och vad du letar efter det?
Varumärket, studie, vad du letar efter det eller är det fortfarande grundar duon och fundamenta?
Bara beskriv ditt mindset lite.
Ja, jag gillar ju att vara i kreativa miljöer uppenbarligen.
Jag gillar kreativa idéer och jag gillar projekt som har rätt storhet.
Jag är en ganska emotionell investerare som en gång i tiden började mikroinvestera på Peppins.
Eftersom jag då råder givet i varumärketsfrågor och har projektled i den världen uppdäckt att det kanske inte är det som de här bolagen som jag har investerat i tänker på.
Främst så började jag höra av mig.
Jag har stått i förfogande om ni vill börja tänka på de här sakerna.
Genom åren har de relationerna stärkt och det har blivit akna upp mer och nya projekt.
Så jag har egentligen bara hamnat i en rolig sammanhang där jag känner att jag kan bidra.
Så den här investeringsdelen som hänger i investerare har varit ett incitament eller en extra morot för att lägga med den här tiden som det faktiskt är frågan om.
Sen så har jag gått in med lite större pengar och investerat i bland annat elbilsbranschen, och fortsatt på den banan helt enkelt.
Är det positivt att vara en emotionell investerare eller är det...
Eller har du skitit sig?
Nej, men jag gör det här för att det är kul och utvecklande för mig, och för att jag hoppas att det såklart ska finnas en uppsida ekonomiskt.
Men jag gör det också av ett vinnande intresse för affärer, fiativitet och varumärken.
Och det förenas väldigt bra i den här världen, och det är därför vi har startat Lyon, för att kunna mer aktivt ta en roll som varumärksbyggare och rådgivare med de här bolagen.
Och där ser jag nu en större möjlighet att kunna professionalisera mitt investering.
Ja, investerierna.
Sen så är det ju just nu så är jag ju inne i nya världar.
Jag är partner med Veahandel bland annat.
Jag hoppas återkomma till podden om ett år när vi har skalat den och det har gått jättebra.
Och jag jobbar mycket med mat, mobility, den typen av områden jag är inne i.
Jag fattar, men är tanken att byrån nu då ska, är det liksom en investeringsbyrå som jobbar av mot någon sorts sweat equity-upplägg eller är det fortfarande ni jobbar som byrå eller är det ett sådant upplägg som är tänkt?
Bland annat, det vore ju inte naturligt känner jag att vi skulle jobba med nystartade bolag utan att själva känna att vi var en del av det.
Så att återinvesterade kunder är något vi vill göra på lite sikt.
Men det är sweat equity, men det är också kapital i takt med att det kommer in, som är tanken att investeras.
Det finns byråer inom kommunikationssverige som har gjort det tidigare såklart, men jag känner inte att det har varit en usp i branschen.
Därför känns det jättekul att kunna förenra de här vädarna i ett varje märkligt samhälle.
Där är vi.
Blir det inte svårt att bibehålla professionalismen i det där?
Om du blir både uppdragsgivare och uppdragstagare och så ska du jämföra det mot företag som du kanske inte investerar i så att man levererar på samma sätt och man finns...
Blir inte det lite bökigt?
Det kanske kan bli, nej, men i allighetens namn så de investeringarna vi vill göra det är ju i de nya bolagen som kommer till oss och har någonting som vi verkligen tror på.
Och då är väl det ett utmärkt sätt att växa tillsammans, tänker vi.
Sen så i de mer etablerade bolagen där kanske vi inte går in i investering, men då har vi ju ändå kunskapen från den världen för att också förstå hur de bolagen ska kunna få mer investering, hur de bolagen ska riktar sig till investerings-
eller kapitalmarknaden för att få in andra och vi har kontakterna.
Så jag tror att det där kommer att gifta sig helt naturligt.
Men det är väl olika sätt att titta på olika kunder helt enkelt.
Precis som alla broar så har man ju kunder som gör en rik, händ eller nöjd eller glad.
Det är ju så man bygger en kundportfölj man byer.
Nu säger det till alla som investerar i folk och har bolag och sånt men då kan man ju uppfatta det som kund.
Om du inte säger hej får vi investera i dig så vet man som kund att man är inte så jävla rolig som kund.
Hur menar du då?
Då är det en kund.
Om det kommer en kund till dig och du inte efter ett halvår säger att du vill investera i dem då vet de att de inte har någon framtid.
Är det så de ska tolka det?
Jaha, nej det tror jag absolut inte men det kan ju vara så att man har en idé om investering.
Men jag känner att det där kommer komma helt naturligt.
Det vore ju förkassligt att säga att man inte vill investera i sin kund men alla tror jag förstår att man inte kan investera i alla kunder.
Ja, det fattar de säkert men jag hade...
Du hade dragit öron av oss där.
Jajamän, nej det hade jag inte.
Det är skitsamma.
En helt annan grej om vi går tillbaka lite till varumärkes-jukset.
Är det en etablerad term varumärkes-juks?
Om jag som företag har jobbat nu, jag har haft Jim Company till 11 år, och så ska jag börja jobba nu med varumärke.
Vad är steg ett då?
Jag tror att man hade gjort en kartläggning av allt, kanske inte allt under 11 år, men mycket av det ni har gjort under 11 år, och tittat på vad som har varit chansigt och vad inte har varit chansigt.
Vad säger ni i sekunder?
Vad har fungerat?
Det är väldigt knutet till dig som person, som jag förstår det.
Du har en stark resa, en stark profil.
Hur mycket av det har varit varumärket?
Hur mycket har varumärket stått på egna ben?
Jag tror att man skulle gå igenom alla de bitar, när man skulle fortsätta bygga på det som är bra, men man skulle också börja titta på vad är det ni inte har gjort?
Hur kan ni ta marknadsandelar?
Det tror jag är superviktigt.
Om ni skulle nå nya kunder, nya kundsegnent, eller kunder som idag väljer någon annan, vad är det ni gör som gör att ni inte har nått dem idag?
Och sen börja fundera på, ja men det kanske bara handlar om att skruva lite på vissa element, färg och form, eller vad det nu kan vara, som har hängt med i 11 år som kanske behöver en uppdatering.
Eller så är det att kliva in i helt nya världar och prova helt nya saker.
Även där är det liksom ett tråkigt svar på det här varumärkesjokset du beskriver.
Man måste nog göra efter 11 år, jag pratade om det som var en kanske varumärkesguld lite grann, nu kläder det nog lite mer tid att tippa på allt ni har gjort, än om ni hade börjat för några år sedan eller för fem år sedan.
För du pratade om det förut som två olika värdar, liksom alltså någon sorts go to market är en värd och varumärke är en värd.
Behöver man, eller ska man ta det i beaktning, eller hur mycket ska man ta det i beaktning för att säga att vi då, skulle, jag vet inte, men ska vi nå en ny sorts kund, låt oss bara hitta på någonting och så märker vi att ja men det här skulle vi kunna skruva på, här skulle vi kunna hitta.
Då kanske vi måste göra om vår affär i grunden, eller vi kanske måste göra något i back-end som justerar för att täcka upp den ändringen, eller vi behöver ändra vissa grejer för att liksom leva upp till det varumärket som vi då ska profilera oss.
Hur mycket väger man in det och är det någonting ni behöver ta i beaktning eller ligger det bara oss företaget att liksom lösa?
Nej nej, det ligger 100% i vår beaktning också och det är det jag menar med att gör man det efter lång tid så blir det ju dyrare och svårare förändringar.
Alltså man blir ett större och större fartyg som blir svårare och svårare att svänga.
Det är ju det som är grejen.
Så här måste man ju ha en väldigt noga affärsförståelse tror jag också för att var man beredd att fatta hur mycket kan man tappa.
För det kanske man gör under en början till exempel om man gör en så väldigt stor omsvängning.
Men jag tror väl i det här att förstå att businessen är liksom A och O eftersom den har funnits så länge vi är så etablerad och är kanonsrik.
Då dräver vi väldigt noggrant arbete med det.
100% det är beaktning och det går ju inte att...
Men det där kan ju också vara så att om man kommer in utifrån och föreslår saker som är helt orialistiska, då går inte det att genomföra.
Det är ju det som är...
Här måste man ju ta det steg för steg och där tror jag att processen blir allt viktigare idag.
Alltså att du köper in på en process.
In på kanske att du vill ha en konsultprodukt, det är däck som sen du ska använda för att ta en assist.
Men i processen, hur man jobbar med varandra, hur villig man är att förändras, det är nyckeln här.
Det finns ju något uttryck som är typ employer branding eller liknande.
Man ska locka till sig folk och göra det på rätt sätt och sånt där.
Det kan ju inte ha varit ett uttryck för 40 år sedan, då var det väl ingen som brydde sig kanske.
Men hur mycket jobbar företag med det?
Och riskerar man inte bara få folk som vill ha...
Jag vet inte, de vill bara spela pingis typ.
Vart ska man dra gränsen?
Hur skönt ska man vara som företag?
Jag är ingen expert på det där, men jag tänker att det jag kan bidra med är väl att du har något som gör att det känns attraktivt att jobba för dig.
Det är coolt, det är roligt, det går snabbt, eller man kommer in i den här gymiljön.
Man får en känsla av att det här är magen, de här vill jag jobba för.
Det är väl det som är.
Sedan finns det väl de som har byggt fönster kring employer branding, men dit så djupt, eller dit kan inte jag gå.
Alla vet ju om att folk på Spotify tjänar svin mycket pengar.
Det måste vara jävligt jobbigt som arbetsgivare på Spotify.
Man vet att när folk kommer dit så kommer de i minimum att begära 300 000 i månadslön.
Det måste vara svinjobbigt att sitta där på de här lönesamtalen.
Alltså någon gräns.
Jag tycker bara att det är spännande, skitsamma.
Där är det svårt när man har gått så långt att ändra sig.
Där måste man ju såklart hålla en viss linje.
Men jag tror att de attraktiva delarna som är återigen de emotionella, hoppningen till att jag vill vara här för att jag tycker att det är coolt, det kan inte underskattas.
Det finns ju ett stort värde i det.
Det kanske gör att vi kan erbjuda lägre löner.
Hur ofta är det vd och grundare som är problemet vid skift i varumärkesbyggande och hur ofta är det faktiskt någonting annat?
Både och.
Det är svårt att säga hur ofta.
För jag tror att det är så himla personberoende.
Alltså på riktigt svårt att säga hur ofta det är en vd eller en grundare.
Jag skulle säga att de har väl oftast, de kan vara de mest visionära och de kan vara de som vill göra stora förändringar, men ju större man blir, desto större organisationen blir, desto fler människor som kommer in, desto mer brandmanagers man har, desto mer måste man anpassa sig till att det ska gå tryck eller enkelt på en mässa, eller färgerna måste vara på ett visst sätt för att ja, det ska vara tydligt och så vidare.
Så att, nej jag skulle väl säga att vd och grundare oftast i min värld är väldigt visionära och vill, för alla vill ju nå framgång.
Och det är klart att om man rådjer i varumärket så är det uppskattat.
Sen kanske man inte alltid håller med varandra och en grundare går gärna sin egen väg.
Men då får man ju bara vara ihärdig.
Jag känner det här efter någon timme.
Jag känner mig nästan mer slut när det gäller kring vad man ska...
Jag funderar på om jag ska skjuta på det här varumärkesarbetet tio år till.
Hur ska man hitta en lucka för att börja jobba med varumärket?
Nu är det ju snöstorm när vi spelar in detta.
Det är liksom container som har fastnat i snön här.
Det strejker i alla möjliga jävla ställen och kunderna är ju svinsura för att det är två meter snö uppe i Norrland.
Hur ska jag hitta den luckan för att sätta mig ner med detta och snacka i tre timmar?
Måste man alltid börja med en jävla konferens någonstans i tre dagar på någon fin orta?
Hur skulle du säga att folk ska börja med detta?
Förutom att man sitter ner och går igenom allting.
Hur drar man igång och hur kan man motivera det?
Tror du att du kommer att känna under de här kommande 11 åren att nu är en lugn stund.
Nej, det kommer aldrig att hända.
Nu jävlar har jag tidigt.
Det är min första fråga.
För det tror jag inte att du kommer att ha.
Jag tror liksom att det finns ingen bra tid att börja med det här utan det är bara att göra det.
Det enda jag kan säga är att om du gör det om ytterligare 11 år då kommer det att bli exponentiellt mycket dyrare att göra något förändring.
Jag tror att du ska hitta människor du litar på som förstår den här vardagen och som är flexibla med hur man jobbar och kanske börja med.
Eller kanske börja veckan med att fråga vilka problem har vi den här veckan utöver det vi ska göra.
Hur kan vi liksom hitta en väg framåt?
Det kommer med erfarenhet.
Så du behöver jobba med erfarna människor i det.
Sen så tror jag att som sagt det kommer alltid finnas.
Man behöver inte börja med en tre dagars konferens.
Man kan börja med att låta någon, släppa in någon som är nära och pratar med människor.
Naturligt kommer in i och förstår och börjar dela hjärna med dig lite grann.
Det tror jag är det viktigaste.
Men det är lite upp till dig att ta tag i.
Men det finns absolut vägar som gör att du slipper vänta elva år till med det.
Det kommer en följdfråga på det.
Jag har försökt stänga intervjuner fyra gånger på grund av tidsaspekten.
Men jag kommer på nya frågor hela tiden så jag kör den också.
Är det inte hopplöst att jobba med ett kreativt yrke där väldigt mycket av ditt jobb måste vara att sitta och spåna idéer ihop med folk?
Hur hittar man gränsen för vad man får fakturera och inte få fakturera av vad kunden godkänner för fakturering och inte?
Det måste ju vara skitsvårt att sätta av gränserna.
Ja, men om det vore så i de kreativa yrkena att man överfakturerade eller hade en överlönsamhet för att man fakturerade för all tid, man satte och idéade, då hade ju den här branschen varit mycket mer lukrativ och det hade funnits mycket större beroer.
Idag är det ju en lågmarginal bransch som krigar för sin överlevnad därför att man inte kan ta det riktigt betalt för för all tid man sitter och tänker på en kund.
Så jag skulle vilja pröva det påståendet och säga att det är helt tvärtom.
Däremot så kan det ju vara svårare att motivera för en att betala för dig för att man känner att om jag fick en idé var ju den och hur omsätts den i praktiken det är ju lite upp till mig kan man känna.
Nej, jag tycker inte att det finns en övre slags...
Nej, jag menar åt tvärtom håll.
Jag menar så som du menar.
Det måste vara helt hopplöst att få betalt tillräckligt mycket för...
Det är ju så, när man går och lägger sig på kvällen så man ligger och tänker på problem, men det är ju helt hopp, du kan inte fakturera för det.
Eller oftast inte i alla fall, det måste vara skitsvårt att hitta.
Eller det kan ju vara en idé som är the shit, men den idén kom du på på semestern när du inte ens hade den kunden längre men skickade över ändå liksom.
Det måste vara hopplöst att jobba med.
Vi skulle gå och prata en timme om hur man hittar lönsamhet i kreativa näringar och det är väl det jag har jobbat med och faktiskt lyckats med många gånger.
Men att börja ta vid tal för idéer, precis som man ska börja testa att bygga ett varumärke eller göra vissa kommunikationsinsatser bara för att se hur de landar.
Så med tiden blir man starkare, för det är i sumbarna av allt man gör.
Börjar man etablerar idéer, sälja dem, hitta kunder som gillar dem, då kommer man naturligt att lägga på 10% nästa gång, för att man värde har liksom ökat.
Det är det man får bygga på och hitta ett självförtroende i det.
Har du någonsin suttit och haft en kund som du hade för tre år sedan, och så kom du på något jävligt smart, och så hörde du av dig till den kunden och bara du, nu har jag något här som ni borde ta.
Kan du swisha 25 000?
Ja, swisha, det är för en idé vet jag inte om det någonsin har gått, men absolut, det finns ju en idébank.
Det här är ett tips till dig kanske, att börja samla på dig insikter om kunder, om saker som händer som du tycker att det här skulle vi kunna snappa upp som samtalsämnen.
Att ha en insiktsbank och bygga det själv, för att du kommer sedan när du kommer på en idé att tänka att ja just det, men jag läste ju att det här kan vara ett intressant ämne för mina kunder.
Vår den här idén jag har, den skulle gå ihop med den insikten.
Och då kan du snabbt omsätta den i kommunikation om du har rätt håll runt omkring dig.
Så att börja dela, starta någon slackkanal, börja dela insikter och länka med varandra, så kommer det där liksom komma naturligt.
Sedan behövs det kanske liksom ett större, någonting större runt det som gör att ni hamnar rätt i varumärkesfrågan.
Men det är ju det som ett sånt MVB skulle bygga åt er då.
Nej men jag köper det.
Jag har ett sånt gammalt Word-dokument från typ 2011, du vet, 2011.
Och så kommer man på såhär, ja det här borde vi fundera på, eller det här marknaden, eller vi ska ju testa det här, och så skriver man bara det där.
Och sen typ åtta år senare så går man, 90% är ju skit.
Men det finns ju sådana här idéer som bara, ja nu är det rätt i tiden, det här funkar nu liksom, det här kör vi.
Så att jag köper det, jag tror att det är sjukt underskattat att, ja men alltså även om du tänker att det här är en bra idé, det här ska jag komma ihåg, så kommer man ju inte ihåg det, utan man behöver ju skriva ner det.
Ja, man behöver få hela organisationen tror jag att börja tänka på de här frågorna.
Det handlar inte bara om att du ska göra det eller att någon brandmanager ska sitta och tänka på det här, utan det handlar ju om att försäljningen ska tänka på hur det är.
Då får jag ha två trådar för att 90% av det jag skriver är ju helvete vad trött jag är på den här personen idag.
Ja, exakt hur du ser ut att se er, det lägger vi inte i, men min tips är att du involverar fler och har någon form av styrning på det.
Jättebra, stort tack Jasper.
Ha en underbar dag.
Tack själv, grymt att du var med.
Lycka till med allt nu.
Jewel är ju precis värdelöst på engelska.
Jewel.
Det är liksom, det är ingen som tycker om det namnet, så att någon gång i framtiden får jag byta till något coolare.
Ja, skitsamma.
Det är inte det vi ska prata om idag.